what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so after making the video on Eric
hill Munger explained I wanted to do a
video on the JSA and honestly it's not
like a temple thing right it's not like
a JSA movies coming out or the team's
returning in DC Comics it's just one of
those things where I just kind of felt
like making a video on them because in
truth I've always liked the idea of the
JSA albeit I'm not you know I'm not one
of those those those guys that kind of
looks at it and says okay that was the
greatest team ever I wanna have a
conversation about these guys I want to
you know offer a kind of you know topic
and explanation on this now the JSA made
their first appearance in all-star
comics number three back in 1940 and
they were created by Sheldon Mayer in
Gardner Fox where really it was Gardner
Fox who made him and then Sheldon Mayer
who edited them but the fact remains the
whole idea of the JSA was landmark when
it first happened because for the most
part you didn't really have teams in
comic books even back then you didn't
really have like crossovers for the most
part it didn't really work that way
instead the JSA was really more of an
anthology series where it was just kind
of a bunch of different stories that
were combined into a singular book
really the kind of idea of a shared
universe in DC Comics didn't really
arise until like Superman number 75 I
think it was when Superman and Batman
met for the first time but there were a
few caveats that went into the creation
of the JSA one of the big misconceptions
that I want to talk about for a second
is how people view DC Comics a lot of
people look at DC and they basically say
okay so like actually comics number one
hit the shelves and DC Comics was born
and that's actually not true the way it
was back then in terms of what we call
DC at this point in time it was actually
composed of two organizations the first
one was national allied publications and
the second one was all-american comics
now national allied publications we've
talked about this before that was Harry
donenfeld and Malcolm wheeler-nicholson
Malcolm wheeler-nicholson was basically
the pioneer of the modern day comic he
was the first one to sit down and
essentially make up heroes so to speak
and then put them in a traditional comic
book form Malcolm wheeler-nicholson was
the first person to do that now Harry
donenfeld was a magazine publisher he
owned independent magazine management or
some along those lines I Kimber it was a
company he owned and actually he was the
guy that Malcolm wheeler-nicholson went
to you in order to basically get the
money he needed in order to get his
stories published the problem with this
was that eventually Harry donenfeld
rousted Malcolm wheeler-nicholson he
actually sent him on a cruise and then
left him high and dry but Harry
donenfeld was basically the run the
running the show and the result was that
you had a guy named Max Gaines who
wanted to launch his own publication
called all-american max Games
effectively what the Harry donenfeld has
said hey look I want to launch
all-american publications Harry
donenfeld gave him the financial backing
to get the company off the ground and
what you ended up having was
all-american publications that was ran
by max games and Jack Leibowitz and then
national a lie that was ran by Harry
donenfeld and was kind of ironic about
this is that most of the characters that
you would associate with being a DC
brand were actually created by
all-american comics the original Green
Lantern Alan Scott Johnny Thunder Jay
Garrick the original flash these are
creations from all American now the
whole idea behind this was that by the
mid 1940s it was apparent that the comic
book industry was going to experience a
collapse of sorts because the popularity
of come of book superheroes was
basically rooted in the popularity of
world war two but when World War two
came to an end and people got tired of
conflict they kind of wanted to let
their imaginations run wild and that
gave way to science fiction rising to
prominence in the late 40s going into
the mid 1950s and so the result was that
max games actually sold off his share to
Jack Leibowitz Jack Leibowitz in turn
sold his share to Harry donenfeld and
all American and national allied merged
into a singular company called Detective
Comics incorporated also known as DC
Comics but the idea of the JSA was that
for the most part the way the rules were
laid down is that you could only have
characters featured in the JSA anthology
series who didn't have their own solo
series the idea was that DC didn't want
to overexpose characters like Batman as
Superman they were already wildly
popular and the belief was that they
were popular because each of them
already had two comics of their own you
had Batman in his own solo series and
then Batman in Detective Comics you had
Superman in his own solo series and then
Superman in Detective Comics by the time
they crossed over you had Superman in
Batman's Comics Batman to Superman
comics and so to throw them in the JSA
would have overexposed them to the
reader and people probably would have
lost interest and so the result was that
when the JSA first met when they first
came together as a team that again
happened in issue number three and for
the first I would say for the first four
issues it was a quarterly series and
then it was quarterly between issues 18
to 27 and then it became bimonthly with
issues 5 to 17 and then 28 to 57 now for
those of you guys who are not familiar
with the way the comic books used to be
published for the most part it was
bimonthly with the really really popular
titles it was how you see it with DC
rebirth right now you got you got
basically a story every two weeks
it was cool because it kind of kept the
popularity going and it was really a
license to print money given how new and
fresh the superhero genre was but when
it came to featuring smaller characters
when it came to featuring less popular
characters it was done orderly meaning
the comic came out once every three
months basically in the first quarter of
the second quarter the third quarter in
the fourth quarter and that was really
it now switching it to bimonthly
was DC testing the waters to see whether
or not All Star Comics had grown in
popularity or decreased in popularity
but again were the first two issues
being anthology the third issue is when
the JSA effectively first met and it was
basically the individual character
sitting down and having dinner and then
telling their own individual stories now
again when it first showed up it was
hugely popular I mean it was massive in
terms of readership because it wasn't
overexposure but it was a lot of
characters that people were familiar
with you know like Spectre and you know
the original flash Jay Garrick you had
Hawkman or least the original Hawkman a
lot of these characters that nowadays
are considered to be wildly popular but
back then were still relatively new now
again this whole pattern of publishing
the series running up until about
February or March of 1951 this was based
on the idea of DC effectively launching
its first relaunch of sorts and the
reason for this is again you know by the
early 1950s the superheroes were losing
popularity you know people were looking
to like space and aliens and Vader's
from outer space some and things like
that and that's really where you know
guys like Edmond Hamilton kind of made
their bread and butter by pioneering
this science-fiction genre and so what
ended up happening is in 1956 it really
1955 we're being honest with ourselves
oh you had this guy named Julius
Schwartz who came along I kind of
assured in this sort of second
Renaissance of superhero comics we call
it the Silver Age and what would what he
ended up doing was basically blending
science fiction with superhero themes
and that's the reason why if you look at
characters like the flash Barry Allen
instead of being exposed to you know
heavy water like Jay Garrick was what he
ended up doing was being doused in
chemicals and struck by lightning and
suddenly he could run super fast
the original Green Lantern Hal Jordan
got his ring from an alien race it was
cool to see this sort of thing take
place Superman's origin story was
expanded to basically say he gained his
powers because Krypton orbited a red Sun
and Earth orbits a Yellow Sun and the
yellow Suns energies allow Superman's
powers to thrive these kind of science
fiction themes being thrown into
comic-book form
helped to kind of uh sure things in in a
new direction the problem with this was
that where some of the characters really
a lot of the characters of the JSA and
kind of just been written out and been
eliminated it really begged the question
of what happened to them with characters
like the original flash Jay Garrick the
original Green Lantern Alan Scott they
were replaced by Barry Allen Hal Jordan
respectively and there was no real
explanation as to how it was that happen
and so because of the fact that DC back
then had maintained a linear continuity
meaning there was no multiverse DC
needed a way to basically explain where
it was the original JSA went to you and
also offer not an explanation of whether
or not they will come back and so the
result was that in flash issue number
123 in 1961 DC created the multiverse in
a story called the flash of two worlds
and it was basically just a story where
Barry Allen crossed over into what we
now call earth 2 and encountered Jay
Garrick the original flash and so by
offering this explanation what DC
basically established was that all of
the stories that took place where very
Allen was running around with Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman that was on
earth one and then all the stories that
dealt with the flash Jay Garrick all the
older stories in the 1940s would like
Allen Scott things like that that was
earth 2 and this again was just DC kind
of hitting a mark perfectly because what
it did is it hit with fans who had read
the old 1940 stories and wanted to see
those characters return and then it hit
with new fans who were curious about the
old characters and wanted to see what
they were about and so what DC did over
the course of really the next several
years is they started publishing these
sort of crossovers between the Justice
League of America and the Justice
Society of America now what did I bear
in mind is the JSA didn't have their own
solo series when they came back during
the Silver Age they just appeared in
other people's comic books they didn't
really have their own solo line there
were some pretty notable stories like
crisis on earth 1 and crisis on earth 2
and different things like that and those
of course took place in the Justice
League of America comics but it was
smart it was a way for DC to basically
bring back the JSA without investing all
this money in a wholly new publication
and if it failed effectively losing all
that money and so because of that by the
time the JSA received their own
publication back in 1976 you had a
handful of writers who contribute to the
whole thing you basically had like Roy
Thomas you had Gerry Conway you had
these guys who kind of helped to expand
and build on the whole idea of the JSA
as it existed and then allowing it to
sort of grow and thrive at the same time
some members receive their own solo
series for a little while it wasn't you
know super long lasting but it was a way
to kind of branch them out a little bit
more but with the JSA returning in
star comics issue number 58 again their
stories kind of continued on
but the JSA was distinctly different
from virtually every version of a
superhero that you saw during that time
because they weren't young the whole
idea with superheroes is that they were
designed to be in some form or fashion a
reflection of the reader and the people
who were involved in comics and that
point in time in that particular era
superheroes were young and they were
vibrant Batman was young Superman was
young they were designed to be
characters that kind of hit back at the
idea that they were a tangible thing
they were a reachable goal for young
people who were checking out comics but
the JSA were older they were wiser they
were a little more experienced and so it
kind of brought to the table this idea
that where the Justice League would want
to go one way the JSA would provide a
kind of guidance now one thing to bear
in mind here is that comic books
themselves by the time the JSA received
their own solo series for a second time
in issue number 58 of All Star Comics
comic books had moved into a darker
realm a lot of that's due to the death
of Gwen Stacy in 1971 by Jerry Conway
the fact that a superhero like
spider-man or early even any superhero
could fail so disastrously as to lose
their love interest what's landmark and
so the result was that with regards to
the JSA themselves this theme was rolled
over into the team and what we ended up
getting were like a lot of introductions
for characters that were really kind of
brought in to be counterparts for
existing characters for example Power
Girl was introduced in All Star Comics
issue number 58 basically being the
earth-2 equivalent of Supergirl a lot of
these characters are kind of expanded on
and brought in characters like Captain
Marvel the original Shazam returned but
it was cool to see this whole era kind
of grow and expand now again the idea of
a team-up between the Justice League in
the JSA was pretty big and it actually
became a summer event for quite some
time I'm pretty sure it happened every
year were the Justice League and the JSA
would team up against some other team I
mean again it was really like crisis on
earth one and crisis on earth two that
kind of set all that off and then it was
just the groups teaming up and they
would you know faceoff where they would
team up with other groups like the new
gods and different things like that
the issue with this was that DC was
struggling with the advent of its
multiverse because of the fact that
there were so many riders that were
contributing to the DC landscape at the
time and because of the fact that there
was an instant access to communications
by way of the internet what it meant is
that the only way to really communicate
with a rider was by either working
directly in the bullpen which is to say
inside DC headquarters itself or by way
of like phone or letter and so what this
meant was that you had all these
different riders riding their own
and doing their own stories a really
good example of this was the character
of Wonder Girl originally Wonder Girl
was Wonder Woman when she was a little
kid but the idea was that Robert can
occur world Wonder Girl over into the
Teen Titans in the modern day and so
what you basically had was Wonder Woman
as a kid in the modern era and that
contributed to the whole entire calamity
of what is the entire publication
history of Wonder Girl Donna Troy in DC
Comics and that's just an example but
the idea of all these varying versions
of different characters of Superman
Batman Wonder Woman the idea that like
Golden Age Batman had died all those
different things it led to a lot of
confusion among readers and so in 1985
Marv Wolfman and George Perez basically
rebooted everything they kind of hit the
reset button and said from this point
going forward there will be no more
multiverse there will only be a singular
universe now in a lot of ways DC
succeeded in a lot of ways they caused
problems for example it was a slow
rollout in the post-crisis landscape
it's not like crisis on Infinite Earths
happen and within the first year every
single care to received a new origin
with characters like Hawkman it was
around three or four years after Christ
on Infinite Earths finished that he
actually got a new origin for characters
like a Black Power girl she never got a
new origin until something like you know
five or ten years after the whole thing
happened with characters like Batman it
was a couple years characters like
Superman it was about one year so when
it came to those different things it was
kind of rolling it all out but with the
JSA they were characters who basically
existed in a different universe but if
there was no more multiverse and the
question became how would DC be able to
justify the existence of the JSA well
the answer to this question actually
came in 1991 in a story that was written
by Archie Goodwin and Dennis O'Neil it
was called Armageddon 2001 now in truth
the idea of tacking the JSA on was
actually an afterthought originally
Armageddon 2001 was just kind of like an
event of sorts that was brought into DC
Comics it basically involved like a to
issue miniseries and then all the
annuals that DC had going at the time
remember you know back then annuals are
basically just filling stories is all it
was you know DC want to test out a new
writer or a new artist they would give
him an annual and then that would really
be about it and so the result with
Armageddon inferno
what DC did is they tacked on the JSA
and simply said the JSA were just stuck
in this endless cycle of Ragnarok they
were effectively doomed to to
essentially face off against the villain
defeat that villain die and then be
reborn again and go through that whole
process
the reason that happened in 1991 was
because of the fact that in the
post-crisis landscape nobody was really
sparing that much of a thought for the
JSA instead all eyes were on like
Superman and Batman and Wally West who
would replace Barry Allen Wonder Woman
different things like that people were
focused on like the core members of the
Justice League and so when the whole
idea came in in the post-crisis
landscape of what should we do with the
JSA nobody really was concerned with it
too much they were just kind of a team
that may or may not make its return now
following this and going into well
really like ninety one ninety all the
way through 1993 for that you know for
about two years or so the JSA received
two volumes the first one lasted eight
issues and the second one lasted ten but
the idea was that the JSA as a group the
ODC was still kind of running into the
same problem they had originally where
you basically had counterparts of
existing characters who were running
around and he was throwing people off
remember despite the changes in the in
the kind of impact the crisis on
Infinite Earths had almost immediately
after it happened DC began running into
the same problem again even though there
was only a singular universe with
regards to like multiple versions of
different characters and so over the
course of these first two volumes
because volume one only lasted about
eight issues and was ultimately
cancelled by artist Mike Carlin who
simply didn't want to draw any more what
DC did is they started grabbing members
of the JSA and throwing them into other
people's comic books for example when
you ended up having Mark Waid who took
over the flash after Mike Barron and
Bill Loeb what he did is he grabbed Jay
Garrick and threw him into the flash
comic and he basically became like old
man flash the other half of this was
that because there was no more
multiverse and because the JSA had been
brought back after the whole cycle of
Ragnarok and this you know repeating
death and rebirth and so on and so forth
DC had to find a way to make it make
sense and so what they said was that the
JSA were actually superheroes who fought
during the 1940s and 1950s and then
retired and the new generation of
superheroes when Clark Kent went to
Metropolis when Bruce Wayne's parents
were killed when Hal Jordan got a ring
that was the new generation of
superheroes those are the ones that
basically took over in the modern day
and it actually worked exceedingly well
because what it did is it basically
provided this scenario where much like
the original you know earth to earth one
stories of so on and so forth with the
JSA what kind of like these wiser
counterparts ease wiser older
counterparts of the Justice League in
this you know new post-crisis landscape
they were the predecessors they were the
ones who fought villains before and the
Justice League kind of picked up after
them and the JSA provided these little
pearls of wisdom here and there whether
it was being featured in the solo
bollocks to whether is being featured in
the in their own individual solo series
the issue with this was that with the
confusion that arose with regards to
like these varying you know degrees of
characters and origins that were kind of
told and retold and different things
like that
what DC did is they looked at the event
of zero hour crisis and time now zero
hour was designed to kind of fix some of
these continuity issues that existed
within the realm of DC for example after
crisis on Infinite Earths we still
didn't really have like a definitive
time as to win like Batman and Superman
and Wonder Woman when they rose to
prominence we were just told
quote-unquote the modern day and so what
uh what's your hour did is once the
event completed it basically led to the
idea of like an actual chronology of
when things took place we got this giant
timeline basically this huge splash
splash page that basically said like
here's when Superman first rose up and
here's when Batman first rose up now
this combined with everything else that
was going on the death of Superman the
events of Batman nightfall the events of
Emerald Twilight when Hal Jordan went
crazy and was possessed by parallax and
all that kind of good stuff all those
things that went on kind of culminated
in this idea that the JSA were slowly
being weeded out they were kind of being
eliminated to a degree and so what this
meant was that DC started looking at
members of the JSA community and saying
which one of these characters which is a
duplicate of an existing character or at
least a predecessor of an existing
character which one of these guys can we
get rid of can we start knocking off now
because of the fact that mark Wade's
flash run was exceedingly popular when
he was riding it there was no room to
get rid of characters like Jay Garrick
but there was room to change characters
like Alan Scott this was especially
prominent because of the fact that Hal
Jordan was basically out of the picture
and Kyle Rayner was the new Green
Lantern and so instead of having Alan
Scott is like the Green Lantern what DC
did is they basically maintained the
power of the star heart quote-unquote
which is basically the earth-2
equivalent of a green lantern removed
the ring of Alan Scott he started
calling himself Sentinel and he was
effectively kind of a rebooted holy new
character the other half of this was
that running up until about 2005 or so
you had a couple changes that went on
with regards to like the JSA title that
ran between 1989 to 2006 that actually
emphasized a lot of the idea of the JSA
being the predecessors of the Justice
League and focusing on how they kind of
passed that torch on how they passed
that mantle and so on and so forth now
running into about 2005 between 2005 and
2008 what you had was a story where a
series called JSA classified
jsz classified is one of those stories
that actually confuses a lot of readers
because a lot of people look at JSA
classified and believe it's actually
part of the JSA continuity and to a
degree it is but at the same time it's
not what JSA classified was designed to
do was to basically say okay look we
told you guys the JSA fought crime in
like the 1950s in the 1940s and so on
well here's what they were doing during
that time and so it's basically telling
the stories of the JSA members when they
were at the peak of their crime-fighting
career before a lot of them were simply
just too old to continue on and
basically just retired and it worked
because it was a way to grab the various
members of the JSA and slowly start
rolling them in to the bigger ongoing
mythos of DC so they didn't feel so
isolated now back in really in 2006 the
JSA kind of experienced this big
resurgence or kind of a reshuffling and
the reason why was because of the fact
that you know between 1985 and 2006 you
only had one universe in DC Comics with
the idea of creating you know Infinite
Crisis on the return of superboy-prime
and you know all those different things
that were going on alexander luthor from
another reality who basically recreated
the multiverse what DC did is when they
brought the multiverse back it was not
the original multiverse it wasn't the
one that we saw from flash of two worlds
back in 1961 instead it was a new
multiverse but it was a way for DC to
bring that concept back and then to take
the various members of the JSA and throw
them onto earth too and give them their
own home and so following this under the
writing of David Goyer and then you know
under the writing of Geoff Johns what
you had was a series of stories by the
JSA where they basically went about and
started picking new people to be part of
the JSA to kind of bolster the roster
and carry on the torch of the superhero
legacy but running until about 2011 when
DC basically rebooted everything between
2009 and 2011
what DC did is they brought in like JSA
all-stars it was grabbing the younger
members of JSA and throwing them onto a
tee now again only lasted about 18
issues but that was because of the fact
that DC rebooted now for what I've been
able to tell JSA all-stars was kind of a
reworking of infinity Inc
but not exactly infinity Inc was
basically like the progeny of
superheroes back in the 1940s it was
kind of like you know the heads more or
less who kind of carried on the mantle
kind of went on and did their own thing
but with regards to JSA Allstars it was
grabbing the younger members of JSA and
throwing them onto a team now again only
lasted about eighteen issues but that
was because of the fact that DC rebooted
funny thing about this was that the
legacy of the JSA running up until 2011
was one of death and rebirth the JSA was
the original DC superhero team
eventually they were thrown into a
different universe and they were you
know parrot alongside the Justice League
of America eventually the Justice League
overshadowed them just by sheer
popularity and the roster of the team
because the JLA was composed of DC's
most popular heroes and with the Justice
League of America experienced these
waxes and wanes in terms of like Justice
League International Justice League of
Europe extreme justice things like that
the JSA largely remain the same in terms
of the fact that when they came back
after crisis on Infinite Earths
their roster was still relatively the
same albeit with a couple of additions
and a few changes here and there but all
this really came to a halt when it was
launched with earth-2 in 2012 it's part
of the new 52 now depending on what era
of comics you come from there were some
who loved earth - and there were some
who didn't like earth - and the reason
why was because for people who were
hardcore about the original JSA they
didn't want to see things change there
was just something about seeing an older
experienced Jay Garrick fighting
alongside Barry Allen he brought wisdom
and experience to the table and some
would argue that was worth so much more
with regards to the earth 2 version it
was a more updated theme it was a more
contemporary theme now the idea of earth
2 was to really kind of tie into the
eventualities of the new 52 coming to an
end so for the most part what DC did is
they brought in a new era of superheroes
by killing off the original superheroes
so really unlike the first issue Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman on earth - are
all killed by Steppenwolf when he
launches an invasion at the f2 behest of
Darkseid and what this did is it allowed
a whole new generation a kind of a
reimagining of existing characters to
basically rise to prominence so like a
reimagined version of Alan Scott a
reimagined version of Jay Garrick
Hawkgirl who was shifted up you know all
these different things were based on the
idea of making the characters younger
more diverse and more interesting and
more entertaining to a wider group of
fans now again earth 2 for the most part
of me from what I've seen with regards
to like the current generation the new
generation of DC readers a lot of people
actually enjoyed earth 2 they kind of
looked at and said it was a great series
of stories until they got to earth to
society but with earth to society that
came out of convergence it came out of
the event that DC launched there was a
zine just kind of be a filler event
while DC shifted offices from New York
to California and so one
up happening is you basically had the
entire event of convergence took play
that took place which is really kind of
a nightmare to explain in and of itself
so just know that it's an event that
happened and so what ended up happening
was the actual earth to earth was
basically moved on from with regards to
the JSA there was really nothing for
there for them anymore because as far as
I'm aware it was totally destroyed by
Darkseid and so the result was that the
JSA basically settled on a new world and
then tried to transform that into Earth
and make it into their own place of
residence and so the result was that
fans weren't really keen on that as far
as a lot of fans were aware earth - it
just kind of run its course it was time
to go ahead and just let it go and it
was DC trying to keep that popularity
going despite the fact that there wasn't
a whole lot of interest there and so
once DC rebirth launched and because of
the fact that DC rebirth is designed to
basically blend what used to work
alongside with what works now the only
thing we do know is that Jay Garrick
exists albeit you know he's currently
being held prisoner by dr. Manhattan as
far as we're aware Johnny Thunder is
just kind of stuck in a retirement home
and that's really about it there's maybe
one or two characters the original Power
Girl is stuck between dimensions at
least as we saw in the Deathstroke
rebirth story and they're just kind of
floating around at this point they're
characters who exist in the DC Universe
in different put in different places and
at different ages it's just a matter of
when DC is going to reconcile all the
characters and basically bring them back
but you know I figured I'd go ahead and
do this whole thing it's tough to cover
like almost a hundred years worth of
publication history within the span of
half an hour it's pretty difficult to do
but would that being said guys if you
are new here to come let's explain make
sure you guys to the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you